indeed the mature player in the world
fabiano carano with us fabi today felt
like
a roller coaster ride a little bit
maybe not so crazy but what were you
experiencing because we were looking at
it thinking the guy is falling like a
rock and then all of a sudden you rose
back again
yeah it was a wild day um
i mean i started badly i wasn't playing
well i i was blundering i i'm
i mean
those two back-to-back games against
jeffrey uh losing i think dead drone
rook ending
and then against chakriar was a horrible
game
so i wasn't feeling too good and then
and then against sam was also a very bad
game but somehow i won that one
and after that things improved um
last game was of course also
wild and and ridiculous but uh
because i started badly the
my my feeling now is more
um
yeah kind of happy with today if it was
other way around i would have been upset
well
is it is it just
like you said the sam game you get a
break and then it goes in your direction
because it's hard to control
how we think when we're on tilt or we're
losing games
you didn't do anything special to come
back you said you basically is what i'm
hearing yeah i actually don't think i
was on tilt um i mean sometimes i get
tilted when i'm playing badly but
i didn't
feel massively upset i think i was just
not not in shape i was just making
mistakes which had nothing to do with
it's not like i was doing crazy things
it's just that once i was getting down
to
to the last few seconds
my my play was really suffering
um
but yeah then after that game against
them i actually i think played two
pretty good games um
i mean not perfect of course but but for
blitz i think pretty decent games and
then the last game was wild but uh
i can't even be upset of course i was
winning at the end pretty easily but he
was also winning for most of the game so
i can't really be upset
uh we actually saw you at two rooks and
could have made it him you ended up
getting mated by him uh yesterday with
with his time i had that thought you had
you did that i thought it would be
poetic justice um but
my works aren't as good as his
finally
it looks like hikaru is going to win
this with seemingly running away with
the score is it important for you to
come in second place
i don't know the scores i mean i i know
that he's uh in the lead i don't know
how massively in the lead i assume it's
pretty much an uncatchable lead but
i mean i wasn't thinking about first
place at the start of today you know
like after after i was minus three i was
just trying to
to not lose any more games just to
stabilize things um the fact that i'm
still in a pretty good position i'm
happy with
um i don't know
i don't know who
who's behind me or how much
he's two and a half points ahead of you
by the way yeah i mean i i don't think
that i'm
catching up with two and a half points
especially since he carves playing well
um so yeah it would be nice to uh secure
second place if possible that would be
good all right well
keep bouncing back enough of the roller
coaster rides oh if i bounce back i have
to do badly so you're
i think you did badly already
let's hope you just rise thanks good
luck
very nice uh fabby just a quick question
for you as uh two players have
distinguished themselves in this first
day of blitz uh liam and uh
hikaru scored six
out of nine your quick thoughts of those
two players
well i mean they're both very good blitz
players we're not too surprised by that
uh
i mean hikaru is a specialist in blitz
and
um
and yeah the fact that he he also did
very well in rapid
i guess it's not good for the rest of us
that he's also finding his foreign blitz
and liam i think started even better
than he finished he might be a bit
disappointed with the end because um i
think he was plus four after six rounds
so he was really
really running away with it but uh it's
hard to come back because of the scoring
system from a tough
uh from a bad rapid result like you have
thank you and good luck tomorrow fabi